just short guy jones the other way
riller cross court ball rising fire why
not why not you're going crazy for
liangelo here in vegas it's his town gus
[Music]
he's got nine points in the third
l'angelo ball for three and he gets to
the drop
so you need a spark plug this is what
you're looking for if you're charlotte
somebody get going and who better than
jello
young man's growing right in front of
our eyes ball hard down the lane high
off the glass
great take by ball the fan favorite
deangelo ball the people's champ they
love him out here in vegas
[Applause]
organized off balance
you're talking about what i like about
tyreese is i think he fits perfectly
with
the aaron fox and buddy
i'm just going to be out of here you got
to move it defender create space
and that's why here's your guy shooting
three
knocks down his first shot of the game a
triple listen to the crowd they are
loving it
somo got into the paint
kicks it out to nobody in particular
they got numbers coming back either way
[Music]
with the slam
and the crowd goes nuts here
just short kai jones the other way
riller cross court ball rising fire why
not
you're going crazy for liangelo here in
vegas it's his town gus they've seen his
journey they obviously know his brothers
and they want to see him make it as well
[Applause]
ball
back in the game
nice play
[Applause]
it's a lot of games with basketball
being able to have that play make that
play
it's charlotte and they got numbers on
the break
ball for three
no ball gets his own rebound
and one three the hard way okay wait he
doesn't get this the part he knew right
away it was going to be short first one
to it and then beautiful floater
and it different here we go ball point
six seconds oh we got it
at the buzzer
that's what i'm talking about
[Applause]
what up it's your boy adam lefkow did
you like that content i know you like
that content hit subscribe for more of
it from bleach report